good evening ladies and gentlemen
and i must also say maybe good morning
to those of us who are joining outside
of singapore from europe and from other
parts of the world
thank you for joining us today at the
dance and green cities
architecture as urban ecosystems online
presentation
and panel discussion my name is
geraldine and i will lead you through
the program this evening
for today today together with a
distinguished panel
we will jointly explore the interaction
between buildings and the city as
ecological system
how do we integrate greenery into a
densely built environment
what benefits does it bring to the
city's inhabitants how can we make a
density more sustainable
livable and resilient these are some
topics that we will explore today
i would also like to take this
opportunity to thank the design
singapore council for supporting this
event
and making it possible with this it is
apt to start off this evening with an
opening address by mr mark rhee
executive director of design singapore
council
mr markuy is a design thinking pioneer
in singapore
having designed award-winning innovative
experiences for both the public and
private sector
as a design veteran with white industry
connections mark has brought the work of
the council to the attention of global
design leaders
he is an architect by training an
award-winning one
who was recognized by the urban
redevelopment authority in 2017
as the top 20 under 45 architects in
singapore that would define the next
generation
please welcome mr mark reed well good
evening everyone
a warm welcome to the dense green cities
webinar
which we at the design singapore council
are proud to co-host with
the singapore eth future cities
laboratory
and the singapore university of
technology and design
i'm mark the executive director of the
design singapore council
i'm also very happy to welcome such a
wonderful and diverse audience from
singapore and also beyond
our shores i understand that today
actually we have guests from europe the
us
and other asian countries as well i saw
a shout out from philippines earlier
so just thank you for joining all of us
this evening or at least this evening
for us
a number of our guests may be joining in
for the first time so i'd like to take a
few moments to actually just introduce
the design singapore council and
actually what we do
as the national agency for design our
vision is actually for singapore to be
an innovation driven economy
and a lovable city through design
our work focuses actually on three areas
first we help organizations and
enterprises actually use design as a
strategy to grow
business and deliver people-centered
public services
the second actually we play a large role
in nurturing industry-ready talent and
enabling a design-minded
workforce for our future economy and the
third
we really want to advance the singapore
brand through
raising design appreciation on home
ground and also emotional connections
with people across the world
through the seminar like the seminar
right now so today's topic on the future
of urban design and architecture is
actually
something that's very close to our
hearts especially mine being an
architect
our dens green cities collaboration
started with the future cities lab and
sutd
the singapore university of technology
and design a few months ago through the
droid organization of an exhibition
hosted at our own national design center
the center is currently shut due to
covet measures but i'd love to show you
some photos of the setup manual
so my favorite part of the exhibition
actually is this central installation of
an organic structure
interwoven with lush ferns
my colleague reminded me he said that
these funds might well be dead when we
get back in
i hope not but this is at least we
captured this beautiful photo
to show what you could have enjoyed if
you were
able to come to our center this also
reminds me of one of
singapore's most stunning buildings the
oasis hotel downtown
which is also featured in the exhibition
later and
which we awarded the president's design
award in 2018.
it is actually one of the projects
showcased in the exhibition that will be
covered in the main presentation
later this evening such architectural
innovation can actually be
contextualized in singapore's wider
national
ambition to be a city in the garden
with an area of around 720 square
kilometers and a population of about 5.6
million people
singapore actually has one of the
highest population densities in the
world
so while it may seem like a luxury to
set aside land for parks
instead of residential commercial or
industrial use
our urban planners actually have
recognized early on that well-designed
natural
nature spaces are essential in a livable
and lovable city now
especially as the country undergo a
circuit breaker
measures that require almost everyone to
work and study from home
included so there's such
quick access to green spaces for short
stroll
or jog in the neighborhoods has actually
been a huge relief to many
and hence we did a poll earlier trying
to understand who was using the nearest
parts and the nearest green spaces
being in a small city state with a
highly
modernized and urbanized population
going in this direction is essential for
residents to thrive and
for the country to flourish so the
future of architecture and planning in
singapore must actually continue we feel
to explore how greenery and density
can be integrated to ensure that we live
work
and play in healthy and optimal
environments
and this is why we're actually proud to
support projects like the dense
green cities project as part of our own
larger design future series which
actually furthers a global conversation
about how design can respond to
challenges
and channel and changes like rapid
urbanization
climate change technology destruction
and other issues shaping society
and increasingly no so going forward
as designers are always reimagining the
future that's what we do best
we believe that introducing their work
to the public will help add to the
current discourse of our future
by providing a platform for our design
such design futures content
we hope to inspire the public to come
together start conversations and
co-create solutions to complex
challenges and of course today
the greatest challenge that we all face
is undoubtedly this covet 19
condemning which is one reason why we're
all actually viewing this from home
i'm doing this for my bedroom and the
pandemic has certainly brought about
devastation
but has also created opportunity an
opportunity for us to reflect
regroup and maybe reimagine a new future
for us all
so i very look very much look forward to
the presentations and discussions of
this evening
and this will undoubtedly uncover rich
insights into this topic
and beyond tonight we hope you'll keep
in touch with us to continue this
exploration
and conversation so really if you're
here do follow us on our social media
through the links here
and stay connected through our mailing
list as we'll be working hard to bring
you more such
content on design futures in the coming
months so
enjoy the evening i think it's very
heartening to know that the design
singapore council is not only trying to
make singapore more livable but also
more lovable
so this is a very interesting dimension
thank you very much
yes um yes and some of you would have
seen the exhibition
and would may know that the exhibition
and the book dance and green series
is based on a research project at the
future city laboratory under the
singapore eth center
the future cities laboratory also known
as fcl is established by eth zurich
and the national research foundation of
singapore in collaboration with partners
including the singapore university of
technology and
design or sutd the program seeks to
shape future cities through its research
based on science by design and in place
in this context the research on dance
and rebuilding typologies
was started as one of the twelve
projects under the program
we had the pleasure today of learning
more about the fcl from professor
stephen kemps
program director of the future cities
laboratory at the singapore eth center
before his appointment as the program
director of fcl he was the head of
department of
architecture and director of the
edinburgh school of architecture and
landscape architecture
he has published books including
drifting migrancy and architecture
the sage handbook of architectural
theory buildings must die
a perverse view of architecture please
welcome professor stephen kentz
hi everybody um very nice to um
join you even if it's uh remote
this is a very interesting kind of new
format i think we're all getting used to
and there's some wonderful opportunities
particularly able to talk to you from
in different parts of the world um as
geraldine said my name is stephen cairns
i'm the director of the future cities
laboratory
um our home university is uh hth zurich
and we've been based in singapore for
some time now and we collaborate with
universities in singapore and also in
the region
as geraldine said our mission is to
shape sustainable cities
through science by design in place
now we're often uh we we're very
interested in the tension between these
three words science design and place
science of course aspires to universally
applicable truths
um place of course is about the opposite
it's about identification of localities
which are different uh be that through
the way it engages with environment or
history or culture
and we like to think about design as a
kind of practice and discipline
that helps link science in place
it's of course no accident that we are
based here in singapore
because singapore has a very particular
an exemplary role in developing a
certain kind of technologically advanced
city
and this has massive uh interest
worldwide
and it is a direct example for the way
in which cities all around us
in asia in this most rapidly developing
region of the world
singapore in a way functions as one of
the kind of prominent models
for developing a city well which is one
of the reasons why
eth is interested in being in singapore
if you're thinking about science design
and place of course this is very complex
quite difficult to do it's obviously
interdisciplinary
and the work that you were here this
evening in is from the project ensign
green it's a great example
of this kind of work uh you'll see the
work of architects urban designers
ecologists landscape architects
sociologists
i even think there are some economists
involved now all of these different
disciplinary figures speak
slightly different languages they
probably all speak
english but i mean by language a
specific kind of
disciplinary language so a certain
approach a certain way of doing research
a certain way of considering something
to be data or not
certain way of publishing and outputting
that research
so in fcl particularly with our
institutional colleagues we've developed
a certain way of thinking about
complex questions uh in inter
interdisciplinary ways and it's not easy
to do and we're very pleased
that you get to see a great example of
that this evening
and then finally uh another thing that
we do is that we are not
solo operators here we interact with
local institutions and of course
singapore university of technology and
design
and design singapore are two of those so
i'm really excited about this evening's
work um i hope uh as mark said please
if we ever get to travel again we hope
that you come and visit us
if not in the meantime please look out
for us on the normal social media
um and website channels thanks again and
have a great
uh have a great session i'll see you
again soon later on
thank you professor steven kentz as
mentioned earlier that webinar is
organized in conjunction with an
exhibition
and also the launch of the book of the
same name dance and green cities
architecture
as urban ecosystem as the author of the
book professor
thomas schroedfer has the challenge of
bringing the exhibition and book alive
through this presentation this evening
he is defining associate head of pillar
of architecture and sustainable design
at the singapore university of
technology and design or sutd
and principal investigator of the dance
and green building typology research
project at the future cities laboratory
he has received prestigious awards and
recognitions including the
asia education leadership award
president's design award
which is the singapore's highest owner
according to designers and designs
across all disciplines please welcome
professor thomas schuffer
thank you geraldine uh good evening from
singapore and thank you mark and stephen
for your introductions also a big thank
you from my side
to design singapore council in the
national design center
singapore for supporting and hosting our
exhibition and tonight's event
so for the next 45 minutes or so i will
try to provide you with an overview of
our work
on dense and green architecture and
cities and i'm going to start
sharing my screen now with you
so before i go into into the actual
presentation
uh i want to highlight that to work on a
project like this of
course you can do this by yourself a lot
of what i'm going to talk about tonight
is the result of hard work over the last
four and a half years on a project
called dance and green building
typologies
which as both mark and steven mentioned
as well as geraldine is part of the
future cities laboratory here
in singapore i'm the principal
investigator of this project my
co-principal investigator is also
joining us tonight is professor sasha
mintz from the eth
zurich we had a wonderful research team
as well
that you can see in the slide here and
we had many many contributors both
from government agencies as well as
practice
so you see it's quite a long and
impressive list of
stakeholders that we were able to work
with over the last
four to five years so
my presentation tonight will largely
go along to major publications that came
out of the
dense and green research one is a book
that came out right at the beginning
of fcl 2
and it is titled dancing green
innovative building types for
sustainable urban architecture so in a
way it
a little bit predates the work that we
did with the future cities lab but it
just shows you
this is a topic that i have worked on
for quite some time
for a topic like this i think it's
important to
not just try to cover this all by
yourself so just like i was supported by
a research team for a book publication
like this
is good to bring in other experts so you
see the list here
it includes some quite illustrious names
including case christians
and so on so what we
try to do with this first book is to
explore
innovations in architectural typologies
that originate from the integration of
green components such as sky terraces
green facades and vertical parks in high
density buildings
so we did this through a series of
in-depth case studies but really very
much
the focus of this first book was an
architectural view so
we felt something is happening there's a
very interesting
new paradigm coming up in the discourse
of architecture landscape architecture
and urbanism
and we felt it was the right time to
explore this through a series of
case studies the second book which is
actually the the basis for the
exhibition at the national design
center and very much the result
of the work of the last four and a half
years at
the future cities laboratory is dense
and green cities architecture's urban
ecosystem which of course is also the
title
of tonight's presentation uh
again there are contributors to the book
um including peter rowe there are some
colleagues from eth
zurich and of course my co-principal
investigator
sasha mends so in this book
we try to
kind of the the research is really on
the emergent understanding of the
building and the city as
ecological systems and
we were very interested in the question
of the interaction of particularly
large-scale buildings with
the city so the question here is in
which ways can buildings contribute to
the ecology
of their surroundings how can urban
districts with their green and blue
networks link up with the elements and
technologies of building design
so again we uh we investigate all these
questions
through a number of essays as well as
benchmark
case studies and as in the previous book
we collaborated with a number of
renowned architects urbanists landscape
designers
as well as government agencies in
singapore so the structure of the book
is what you see below we start with what
we refer to as
dance and green agendas that is followed
by a second part of the book which talks
about dense and green
dimensions that's really the kind of
scientific
backbone of of the research that we did
followed by the case studies and
kind of a speculation of where all of
this is going to lead us in the future
so i'll use the books as i said
as a as a kind of an image
backdrop for the argument i'm trying to
make here
so we start with the emerging dense and
green paradigm
and when you look back in history of
course
the idea of integrating landscape
architecture and architecture is
is not really new and
this uh image this um engraving from the
19th century
uh depicts uh one of the seven wonders
of the ancient world which
are the hanging gardens of babylon and
you see
probably an architecture that at that
time would go for
a high-density building but you see even
though this is just an imagination of
what this building might have looked
like
you see a very close integration of
greenery
and and architecture so when we fast
forward to
modern times this is 1931
uh the famous villa savoir by le
corbusier so with the modern movement
there are again these these ideas that
the building could somehow integrate or
at least
replace the the greenery
that it occupies with its footprint on
the ground
on the roof level so this certainly
was a was a paradigm shifting project
in the history of architecture
again we fast forward another 70 years
to the year 2000
and the very important expo 2000 that
in that year took place in hanover in
germany
and a lot of the discourse of this event
was uh
on sustainability providing better
models for
future cities and also architecture in
such future cities and what you see here
in the in the images is what i think was
a very important project in
in that respect it is the netherlands
pavilion by
mbrdb and you see uh literally the
architects
stack uh landscape and architecture
in a building that is then topped by uh
energy production this case uh windmill
so it's i would say it's not so much a
building but more a statement about
what future architecture and landscape
architecture in a highly populated
place like the netherlands could could
look like
so here you see that building in
elevation
and this image is not taken outside of
the building it is
somewhere in the middle where you see
that
the architects literally took nature as
the structure
for for the pavilion
again we jump forward to the year 2008
so more recently we see a lot of
explorations of this
uh combination of landscape architecture
and architecture
uh this is one example on the left is
adelie jean nouvelle's 10 000
santa monica boulevard in los angeles
this is not a build
example but it shows you that the disco
certainly is is very interested in uh
in this combination and this in a place
california los angeles that is not
necessarily known
for sustainable architecture
on the right you see a build example
that we have also studied
as part of our research it is stefano
berry
architects bosco vertical in milan from
the year 2015
and here you have a larger image of this
project so i think this one is a very
interesting
example of a dense and green
architecture in europe
so a couple of things to highlight here
the building is certainly
bigger larger than its urban context so
there is an
idea of densification and the ambition
of the architects here was not just to
provide a beautiful small skyscraper
with luxurious residences but
also to do something for the immediate
urban environment that it is part of in
this case it is a very polluted
air polluted part of milan and
the ambition of the architects here was
through the use of plans in this case
literally providing a vertical forest
for the city of milan
to improve the environmental quality
of of the district
here's a little bit closer up the same
building so you see
a large cantilevering balconies
occupied with quite
intense greenery all of this is
done in collaboration with botanists
so this is uh very much maintained
it changes color over the course of the
year
so in addition to offering environmental
services certainly there's a there's a
quite an interesting aesthetic
that emerges from uh projects like this
closer to home here in singapore this is
the project that
mark mentioned in his introduction this
is wahas
o asia hotel downtown seen from
street level a very interesting building
here in the heart of the central
business district of
singapore so you see what originally
started as a
screen facade in red you see this
on the upper part of the building is
slowly
overgrown with greenery from behind the
facade
so ultimately this project will be
an entirely green green building in the
heart of
singapore this is the same building
seen from what i believe is level
26. so uh we're looking down
on one of the very very large sky
gardens in that building
in fact about 80 percent of this
building
are sky gardens only about 20 percent of
the building
is in closed volume it is a mixed use
uh project so it has a hotel it has
office buildings
it office components it has
some residential components all of this
is combined in a in a high density high
livability
uh project power excellence
in our research over over the last
couple of years we have looked at the
many many aspects of such dense and
green buildings
including of course the the technologies
that
go with this so i will just give you an
overview of the various
dimensions that we were interested in
so this for example is a contribution by
atelier 10
nari pinyabatana who looked at
how buildings with greenery perform
better particularly in the tropics
because in the tropics it's all about
cooling buildings and of course the
greenery can
can help with exactly that but we also
looked at
the buildings the dense and green
buildings contribution to the urban
context that is
it is part of so think about urban heat
islands
uh and of course a building that works
with a lot of greenery can help
to mitigate
urban heat island effects as well
we have looked at the aspects of blue
green
infrastructures for buildings in livable
cities and for this
uh we worked for some time with herbert
eiseitel
who you might know is a is a very well
known uh
landscape architect german landscape
architect who did some really pioneering
work
uh including the one that you see in
this slide here on the right
is potsdamer platz in berlin the year
2000
where retention ponds were included
in the center of what is now a very very
dense part of
the capital of germany but it's not just
the functionality
of of blue and green that have advised
was in here and discusses
in his essay it is also uh
the the kind of new quality you see the
livability aspect uh
that comes to the foreground quite
nicely
we have looked into biological
functionalities of
green and this dimension includes
for example how greenery reduces soil
erosion and regulates water flows in
cities
how greenery can help improve water
quality how it improves air quality
as mentioned in the case of
of stefano berry's project in
milan we have looked at the very large
scale as well
here's a contribution titled green
urbanism
models of a dense and green urban
context by case
christianza who was very much involved
in
what's still the current phase of the
future cities laboratory
and he's not he was he's retired now but
he has also an important practice
in in the netherlands kcap
which of course executed projects like
this
all over the world zooming in
on the on the architectural scale um
there are very interesting implications
of what we refer to
the as the dense and green paradigm for
dense and green building
typologies uh for example museums
and the example that you see here on the
right is hearts of demeron's
miami art museum from
2013 and this is a great example
also in a tropical context how
greenery is woven through a series of
boxes that
contained actual museum content so in a
way the
the result is both landscape
architecture and architecture
and it's not just aesthetically a very
interesting effect
again because of the proximity to the
water in this case
and the occasional flooding of the area
that this
building is part of it also has
it it has it provides a very important
ecological service to the city of
miami this is all to highlight that of
course dance and green buildings are not
something particular to
singapore but i would say that
these typologies have been experimented
with all over the world
so on the right you see another example
a very famous example by now which is
james corner field operations steelers
video and renfros highline
in new york uh from the year 2008 here
in a larger image
so it's a very interesting uh idea to
adapt
um in this case an old piece of
infrastructure an elevated
railway uh that ran through a good part
of
lower manhattan all the way to midtown
and to make this
a linear park and this project as i'm
sure you know
uh is not only famous but has also been
inspiring many other projects all over
the world
including mbrdb's solo
project in seoul in korea
talking about the dense and green case
studies that
we have looked at i would like to start
with
the kutek quad hospital here in
singapore which i think is
is a very interesting institutional case
kutek bot hospital was located
in a much bigger campus before it moved
into its new
building that you see here on the on the
photograph
and as the the hospital had to move to
its new location with a much smaller
footprint
the the management of kutek but
asked the architects to please
help to maintain the quality of the old
hospital
with its lush setting and a lot of
greenery
around it and to bring this somehow in a
high density project and of course the
approach that the architects took
because there is no
no other option is to fold the greenery
into the
into the vertical dimension of the
project
so what i'll show you here are the
section of the building
i believe that you can see my mouse
moving over the drawing
so you see how greenery is included on
multiple levels
there's a very large kind of atrium
space
and the building opens up to an adjacent
urban park so it makes
direct connection to this it kind of
pulls in the
the local ecosystem into the building
and folds it up into the vertical
dimension
what you see on the left are two shots
of this project taken
on different levels um none of them
being the ground floor
so you see the greenery is is
very prominent on all the levels you see
sky bridges
planter boxes used everywhere and then
on the lower image
you see a very interesting component
which is an
urban farming component that the
architects decided to
include and that has been very
successful
in uh growing uh
all sorts of things that are consumed by
the hospital itself
but it is also a way to bring in
uh the the neighbors of the hospital so
it is
uh not just run by the hospital but
indeed it actually functions as a
as a social connector for the whole
urban context that this project
is part of which in a way is is a good
moment to introduce also the social
component that we're interested in
in these projects so greenery can of
course bring people together be it in
the form of
just a simple sky garden that is a
common or public space in a project
but certainly also with urban farming
that has
gained tremendous popularity in
singapore over the last couple of years
another institutional building i
would like to mention here is school of
the arts a project by
voja it predates
the asia hotel downtown by a couple of
years
but you see here in the view from the
adjacent dolby gold green
which is an urban park you see the
inclusion of greenery on the facade and
when we look in the upper right
we look at the building straight on from
the adjacent
green public space you see how the
architects divide
the the massing into three blocks and
in a way they pull the greenery through
this uh through these void spaces
throughout the building
and you see in the section uh how the
footprint is replicated as a green space
uh on top with uh trees and a running
track that connects all these three will
volumes on a higher level so again is is
the same
idea that the building section in a way
becomes an extension
of the adjacent urban green
u space we are going to another typology
now we're looking at an early example of
a residential typology here in
singapore newton suites by the same
architects
boha and
to to work on a residential project of
this size it is actually very important
for the architects
to break down the volume into uh
parts um and includes common spaces that
bring people together so this is an
early example where you see
the cantilevering uh small green spaces
every five levels that in a way
introduce a kind of a mini neighborhood
in an otherwise
very or fairly large uh residential
uh development so this is then combined
with
a green wall that runs the entire
uh height of of the building so on the
left
in the the the aerial view you see this
uh these these common spaces
for uh for the residents of newton's
suites
as well as in the section you also see
that
otherwise very utilitarian structures
like
the parking garage are used for
again a common space where there's a
blue space there's a
there's a pool uh there's a lot of
greenery included and you see
that again the greenery is pulled up
from the ground level
all the way to the very top of the
building
so this is a private residential
development
but these strategies have since then
also been employed in a number of
housing public housing projects or
housing development board
projects in the context of singapore
here you see a bit closer up a typical
unit and
i want to highlight here again the
section so as you live in one of these
units you have a visual connection to
a tree a green space right in front of
your unit
another great example in uh in our
opinion is
uh the the interlace by oma
and bureau ole sharon rsp architects who
are the local architects for this one
this one is a very interesting project
because it also offers
a completely different take on uh
the typology the type of a residential
development so it is not the typical
podium tower typology that you see in
many many of the
the developments here in singapore but
in a way it rethinks this and breaks
down
a very large volume in a series of
blocks that you see here in plan
that then enclose smaller
common courtyard spaces and of course
they also introduce
these sky gardens and roof gardens that
part of them are common so they're open
to all the residents of the interlace
part of them some of them are
part of the the units that are adjacent
to them
but you see here in the in the aerial
shot here give you the
bigger aerial
photograph so you see there's a very
interesting again
combination of landscape architecture on
multiple levels
uh in the project um as well as a kind
of a an opening up
of what would otherwise be a very
large bulky volume and i'm going to use
this project also to highlight that
often architects of such developments
they try quite consciously to connect to
larger urban blue and green systems
in this case you see here in the
background
uh southern ridges singapore southern
ridges which is a green
corridor that runs uh east west
in in the southern part of the island
and the architects try to to pull this
into into uh the massing
of the project and there are very
interesting effects in terms of
biodiversity
as well as rainwater retention and
release
and serving some of these bigger urban
uh blue and green networks with a
project like like this
just to give you an idea of the the
scale of a project like
the interlace so the interlace has uh
just over a thousand units so that means
is about three and a half thousand four
thousand people that
live in a development like this so it's
it's quite a massive scale
and i would say it justifies to look at
buildings like this
as as almost kind of small
small city districts
we have covered residential developments
we have looked at
institutional buildings so now we have a
quick look
at some infrastructure examples
some of you who are here from singapore
or from the region i'm sure you're
familiar with the
singapore's airport changi and it's
terminal three i think is
a prime example for exactly that kind of
thinking in an
infrastructure project so in terminal 3
the architects decided to include
greenery
on a fairly impressive scale on the
interior of the building
and you see here all of this is topped
with quite an interesting roof
that allows for daylight to filter and
in a way provide
optimum daylight conditions for the
plants underneath
this roof was designed by the the
american firm
som so here you see the result
[Music]
again greenery greets you as you as you
move to this building
uh everywhere and the the most recent
development
in in changi is
of course the the jewel which i would
say uh
pushes this this whole idea of the
integration of greenery
in an infrastructure project to the
extreme
so we're looking here at a rendering but
now of course the project is completed
of
the the so-called jewel a project by
safti
architects and what i want to highlight
here is the section of this
building so it is a commercial project
yet the client and the architects
decided to
have a very large kind of
botanical garden on on the interior and
make this
uh the heart of the whole of
shanghai airport and i would say that
that actually says a lot
about how singapore
thinks about the integration of greenery
again let me stress here that this is
not a public project this is a
commercial project of course
and still the clients believe that
including
such an attraction uh on the interior of
this building
would uh allow itself uh to be marketed
in the
in the kind of most optimum uh way
so this is by the way this is not a
rendering this is the the actual
uh jewel as it is today
the examples i just shared with you were
mainly singaporean examples
i just want to include here one that we
also looked at
over the last four and a half years
which is one central park
another project by atelier jean nouvelle
in in sydney in australia fairly recent
project as well
and i chose to include this in today's
presentation
because it shows some interesting
aspects in a different
climate in this case the building
shows the building section here shows a
very large
mirror that helps to
redirect the sunlight into the depth
of this atrium space here
that extends below ground level and in a
way the help of
with the help of technology a dense and
green building
is is possible uh in a in a climate that
otherwise would probably be more
problematic in terms of uh achieving the
necessary
uh daylight that you need for the plants
to grow so i think this
uh is an interesting example as well
again it is a high density
project a mixed-use project so it is in
a way a
small vertical city here on the upper
right you see
again the the technology part the
heliostat
or the mirror that helps to redirect the
light and allow plants to grow on on all
levels
of of the building by the way the the
greenery
is uh designed by patrick blanc
uh quite a well-known uh botanist from
france who has worked with herzog
cameron
and many other important current
practices
on a number of projects all over the
world
in our research we very much like to
bring in the knowledge of the
practitioners that have explored such
buildings over
over many years and i think it's it's
fair to say that fostering partners is
certainly one of the
pioneers of including green spaces in
high density
buildings so they provided us with
their knowledge on in this case
environmental performance optimization
on the urban and the building scale
projects that
seminal projects that they uh authored
of course include the commerce bank
building in frankfurt
unfortunately i have no slide of this
here but it is a
high-rise building in in germany that
includes green spaces
on multiple levels so i think that was
one of the early ones in europe
another one includes the the gherkin in
london
or projects such as the one that you see
here on the on the right which is called
the great glass house
and you will obviously see the
resemblance of
projects that that predate the jewel
by 18 about 18 years
with what is currently going on in a
place like singapore
we have worked quite closely also with
mvrdb
a well-known dutch practice
uh i shared with you earlier in the
presentation they are
important netherlands pavilion from the
year 2000 so this is certainly another
example of a practice that has engaged
with the inclusion of green spaces in
many many of
their projects over the years the
project that you see here is mucky next
is a
project that has not been executed yet
from the year 2012 a rendering
for shopping mall in the heart
of barcelona in spain where
the the volume of the building is
pushed into the ground and it gives
them the architects the opportunity to
have a continuous
green space public park on the
on the rooftop which they felt was was
important for this
very dense part of the city of barcelona
these are other examples including the
one on the right
a project called peruvia 88 in jakarta
from the year 2012 a massive mixed-use
building
that includes greenery landscape space
common
and public spaces on on many many levels
this project is currently on hold but
nevertheless
i decided to include it in the
presentation
just to in a way illustrate where the
discourse stands so
if architects could they would probably
push building design in in this
direction
so we're back here with boha a practice
that of course because of the
the physical proximity uh we're in here
with them in singapore
have worked with on on many many of
their projects meaning they have
provided us with
a lot of their insights for for our
research
so here again you see on the right uh
the school of the arts in a
in a section and what i referred to
earlier the extension of the green space
the week out green public green space in
the heart of singapore
all the way through the building all the
way up to this
connected roof with a running track
for the students of this this
institution
i mentioned earlier when i spoke about
the newton suites the private
residential development that
since that project voha has also been
able to
bring these ideas these design
strategies in some of the
projects that they did for public
housing
for the housing development board here
in singapore here is an award-winning
project on the left
uh titled um skywheel
at dawson a massive development
uh roughly the same scale like
the interlace that i shared with you
earlier so again you see
quite nicely in the building section the
inclusion
of green common spaces for the residents
a roof garden that tops all of this and
you see
uh here to the to the left uh the use
of uh the parking structure as a
as a kind of a small neighborhood uh
park on an
on an elevated level
we have also worked with ken young
and you know if i refer to some of the
other practices
as pioneers i would say he is really the
pioneer among the pioneers
he is responsible for a number of
projects
uh here in singapore including the
the national library and he is certainly
one of the
the the architects that for a long time
have thought about
uh both on the building scale as well as
on the urban scale
about a meaningful integration of uh
green and and architectural design
he has in more recent years he has
also participated in a number of urban
scale competitions here you see
uh his proposal for hong kong our loon
master plan
from the year 2009 because what we see
in a lot of these architects uh
thinking is of course the realization
that
dance and green building makes most
sense when it is connected
to a larger urban green
and blue system
so where does all of this
leave us and what is there to say about
the dense and green future so
certainly some of the the practices that
we have
worked with over the years they have
they have all developed
their their ideas and at times
visualized these ideas for
what a dense and green urban future
might look like so i give you here
as a big image rendering from
the year i believe 2011
by voja so
certainly this is a practice that has
over the years
gained a lot of experience with
this this building type this denser
green building type and here is a
vision that they put forward in the
context of a design studio
that they ran here in singapore at the
national university of singapore
with a number of students so you see
these ideas playing out on a really
massive scale for those of you who are
not familiar with singapore singapore as
land scores
in other words space is is limited so
therefore i think
singapore for quite a number of years
now has been on the forefront of
experimenting with
building types that do not sacrifice
livability ideas of
large public and common spaces
but really to explore how those
amenities and services in the city can
be
can unfold on not just the ground level
but on multiple levels so this is
a kind of a visionary example of this
it's called
a permeable lattice city
so you see here in the background you
see a stadium
you see parks you see
productive landscapes you see
windmills so it is really uh
clearly the ambition to to provide a
vertical city
but also a livable kind of a
livable vertical sustainable environment
i already mentioned that singapore
uh in many respects is is on the
forefront
of uh the exploration of
many of the aspects that i discussed
over the last half hour or so in 2012
there was a special edition by
architecture and urbanism which of
course in the field of architecture
urban design urban planning is a very
important
publication uh this
edition was titled singapore capital
city
for vertical green so clearly
what is stated here is not not just an
architectural agenda or the agenda of
some
urban design practices but it is clearly
an agenda for the whole of singapore so
i would say that singapore
has for quite some time now of course
recognized
the importance of these developments
and of course has
since its foundation independence
in the 1960s always been
interested in first being a garden city
and then later the planning paradigm
changed to
being a city in a garden and what is now
discussed on the level
of planning and policy making is making
singapore a city in nature so
i think this uh this special edition of
architecture and urbanism highlights
that
it is indeed a very fertile ground that
these experiments that i shared with you
fall
onto uh in the context of singapore some
very recent developments uh to
uh in a way illustrate where the
discourse stands right now
and where the practice of architecture
and urban design stands right now
this is again a very recent quite a
massive mixed-use development in
the central business district of
singapore it's engenhofen architects
marina one and what i would like to
highlight here is
one of course again the the inclusion of
green space on multiple levels so we're
not on ground level here
we are somewhere on level 10 i believe
in the building so there is a massive
atrium space that is lush and green
and is accessible
by everyone in the central business
district area
but here's really what i'm trying to get
at again you see the strategy
is to connect to an adjacent
urban green space to pull the greenery
over here two levels in the building
provide an atrium space on multiple
levels
and then replicate green spaces
throughout
throughout the project so this is not
just uh
to again to provide a nice slush and
green environment which i think
already is an important achievement but
there are many many
uh interesting uh massing strategies and
technological
uh aspects to the inclusion of greenery
in this project
that also come with the dense and green
paradigm in architecture
another example i want to quickly share
with you
is a very recent project again by
boha titled kampung admiralty
i would argue it is a high density
project
it is catering to the elderly
population which with demographic change
that happens here in singapore as well
as in many other parts of the world
is is somehow uh an important aspect to
to deal with for architects and urban
designers but what this project does
is uh it layers
multiple programs public programs uh
commercial programs on the
on the ground level with programs that
cater to the elderly population such as
doctors hospitals
all sorts of uh things that deal with
physical therapy
uh that that would be good for elderly
communal facilities
etc it combines it with uh
elderly uh housing in in these towers
on the side and all of this is topped
with a very large
green elevated park so this picture is
not again not taken from ground level
but from somewhere up
so you see uh what kind of uh
high quality uh high density urban
environment is achieved in a in a
project like this
i think it becomes even more obvious
when we look at the
building section so again this is not
just
to have a nice greenery
included on multiple levels but it
serves
multiple functions it filters rain water
uh it helps with urban heat island
effects and so on and so
on so it covers many of the aspects i
touched on
earlier in the presentation this uh
another project we have studied over the
the last couple of years is punggol
waterway terrace is won
by a group 8 asia
and aida's architects and
i included this project because it shows
very nice the inclusion
of in this case a sunken green space
in one of these courtyards
in fact this chord it is called
a jungle coordinate and again this
courtyard connects what you don't see
here on the slide on the right
to a linear green and blue space that
connects the building
uh to the larger networks
of the city of singapore
this image shows you uh
it illustrates in a way the the
tremendous interest that we have
received in the work that we have been
doing over the last couple of years
this is our exhibition at the 2018
venice biennale and we are supposed to
be included in this year's biennale
as well but of course as you know
because of the kovic situation
uh we don't know if it's going to happen
when it's going to happen it's gonna
it's currently scheduled to open at the
end of august but
i guess we all have to stay tuned if if
it actually happens so if so
please go there have a look at at our
exhibition there
coming back to the more scientific
aspects
of our research we have of course with
the future cities laboratory
use the scientific methods to understand
better
uh the services that these buildings
provide
so we have looked in a lot of detail
into the question of biodiversity so are
there biodiversity services these
buildings provide
the short answer is yes the long answer
unfortunately in the interest
of time i have to refer you to
to our book so we have looked at plans
we have looked at
animals and indeed what we found
compared to control cases around the
buildings that we studied is that
there is a very positive impact that
dense and green buildings have on
biodiversity
we have looked at the aspects of
building performance such as surface
temperature which of course particularly
in the tropics as i mentioned earlier is
a very important aspect
where it is a lot about the cooling of
facades
so clearly we we can
show that the use of greenery in dense
and green buildings
helps with bringing down the cooling
load
and that of course translates to
bringing down the energy needs
of dense and green buildings so for this
we have put sensors in buildings
and taken thermal images
and so on so we have used multiple
methodologies to understand this we have
also looked at the
construction and maintenance costs of
integrated green spaces
in buildings because we found that very
often when we present our research that
is one of the the first question that
comes up is yeah it's all nice and
beautiful
but isn't it very expensive so
of course we cannot talk for the
the whole world but certainly the cases
that we have studied
in singapore what we found is the
increase in construction and maintenance
costs when you do a dense and green a
typical dense and green building
in in this climatic context that we're
in is about
three to five percent but what is
interesting
is uh that we also found that the return
on investment
is quite substantial so i give you just
one example
which is a hotel here
the park royale on pickering by boha
architects which is a dense and green
building
which is a four-star hotel but it
charges
five-star hotel prices and interestingly
dense and green buildings have a
positive uh impact uh
economically not only on uh
their their own space but also on the
urban space around them so a project
like um
asia hotel downtown also leads to an
increase
in in rents of buildings that have now
the the very nice view of this building
right in front of them
we have studied in quite some depth also
the economic benefits of vegetation on
and around
residential developments so are willing
are people
willing residents willing to pay more to
live in a dense and green building
and again the short answer is yes and
we have looked at this in the context of
singapore
we have looked at this in multiple
locations
on the on the island and i think we
found some very very
interesting results which again
unfortunately in the interest of time i
have to refer you to
uh to our publications
uh before i conclude um i give
you one example here of a typical case
study
in the book that served also as the
basis for
our current exhibition at the national
design center so we have studied a
project like
o asia hotel downtown in terms of
its green contribution to the larger
urban
context that it sits in we have
then looked at the architectural
strategies and mapped all this
in a series of isometric drawings that i
exploded that you see here on the right
we have looked again at aspects of
biodiversity
terms of plants in terms of plants as
well as
animals we have studied in great detail
uh surface temperature so the energetic
performance of buildings like this and
the positive
impact that greenery can have on the
building uh
in this case behind the screen and
we have looked at the space use the
social component
so how do people actually use these
spaces what do they like about them do
they use spaces that are green more than
spaces that are not green
in in quite some detail and we have
provided
these so-called social heat maps and you
see an example
to the right where we tracked over the
course of
days and weeks and months the use of
green spaces common and public green
spaces in such buildings
so i will conclude with
this image which is one of my favorite
photographs of kampung admiralty
because it talks about in my opinion a
beautiful
integration of of livable space
green space high density uh architecture
in a in a quite dense part
of singapore and i want to conclude with
this short statement here to also
provide a segway to the panel discussion
that will follow density
as many of the denser green projects we
have studied demonstrate
can be designed and designed well it can
be the ultimate test of intelligent
design
and at its best make our cities more
beautiful
more livable more sustainable and more
resilient
and with this i will conclude and
stop sharing my screen so back to
geraldine please thank you professor
thomas schroeder for bringing us around
the world
to view exemplary green architecture
that not only inspires
but also stretches our imagination so
right now before we proceed to the next
section which is
um the panel discussion we have launched
a poll
to get a sense of what you people in the
audience are experiencing
so the question is what is the furthest
you would walk to a green feature or a
park
two minutes five minutes ten minutes
fifteen or more than fifteen minutes
please take some time to fill up this
survey the shots a day
so here we've got most people would walk
ten minutes or
even up to 15 minutes to reach to reach
a nearest park or a green feature
i think that's that's great we shall
begin the panel discussion
firstly by introducing our panelists so
earlier on we had already introduced a
few people
mr mark rhee executive director of
design singapore council
we have professor stephen kentz program
director of future cities laboratory at
the singapore ethics center
professor thomas schroedfer professor
and funding associate head of pillar for
architecture and sustainable design
at sutd and now
also joining them in this panel
we have professor roland bofane he is
associate professor in engineering and
product development pillar and sutd
professor buffenet is also the director
of sutd applied complexity group
that conducts interdisciplinary research
at the interface of complexity science
artificial intelligence and engineering
design he is also the co-principal
investigator
of the city's urban science and design
for density research project
at sutd he is finally also research
associate with the department of
mechanical
engineering at mit
up next we have miss sri lalitha
gopalakrishnan
she is landscape architect and first
vice president of the council of the
singapore institute of landscape
architects
orsila sri has over 15 years of
professional experience
and a diverse portfolio of projects
across singapore malaysia
china hong kong and india she worked
with tierra design in singapore for over
11 years
on projects ranging from residential
commercial
hospitality institutional recreational
to master planning
with many other projects many accolades
last but not least we have professor
sasha mans
his professor for architecture and
building processes at eth zurich
and code investigator of the dance and
green building typology research
projects
at the futures cities laboratory as
thomas has mentioned earlier
he also served as dean of the department
of architecture
founded and led the institute of
technology in architecture at eth zurich
and he founded sam architects and
partners in 1997
where he has been actively engaged in
architectural competitions
throughout the world these publications
include
public space evolution in high density
living in singapore
and three books on the building process
so here we have six panelists for this
evening
so in this panel we will discuss impact
of density in cities and
impact on city dwellers what is the
value of
green buildings in high density cities
can density be designed to make cities
more livable
sustainable and resilient and at a time
of pandemic how can we reduce the
vulnerability
of a density so perhaps we'll start off
a panel discussion with mark so mark in
your opinion
first of all why do we need to discuss
about density why is this an important
topic
i mean i think obviously density is uh
it's important for a variety of reasons
i mean
we've learned that density actually has
been very real
and has even sort of deadly effects
i mean the most obvious example being
the rapid spread of the virus recently
in sort of
more highly urbanized sort of cities
that we've seen
so obviously singapore being a city new
york
i mean you see that definitely we also
learned that by
but alongside that um the idea of sort
of
density being able to just be intensify
some of these things we've also learned
that by
2025 i think more than 600
cities actually will have a population
of over a million people
so really this whole discussion of
actually how to live well in such
environments actually
therefore really come at a very timely
moment and um
all the more with the current situation
so what i hope to actually to discuss
with my fellow
panelists tonight and our audience as
well as how can we actually collectively
reimagine
our future cities and spaces that
actually can't allow can allow residents
to be safe
healthy and thriving at the same time
thank you mark uh next we move on to
professor sasha mense in the dance and
green building typology research
projects
you looked at the different benefits of
green building typologies in high
density cities
including environmental social economic
and aesthetics
do some of these needs sometimes compete
and how should
planners and designers deal with this
competing needs thank you
geraldine and welcome to everybody from
switzerland still cold here as you can
see
i'm wearing a jacket and you're all
sitting in the tropics
and of course dancing green is also a
big question
in europe and of course also in
switzerland our cities are not as
tense maybe paris or london but other
cities
not yet but returning to your returning
to your question
yes on one hand
interdisciplinary approach respects the
different stakeholders involved
this is what we do we work
interdisciplinary thomas
has depicted it brilliantly before in
his
in his speech and you you can see that
it's it's not
an architect alone it's it's a diversity
of people scientists engineers designers
involved and all around questioning
economic topics at the end the economics
in our world are basic are the major
topics
but still it's not the only one all the
social questions which came up
also by thomas how people use
these spaces how they like them how they
even appropriate these spaces if they
don't have maybe a clear function
it's all questions which stand for my
opinion
at the at the beginning and on our top
and in this sense it's interdisciplinary
interdisciplinary research and it will
maybe also
change let's say also the metier
our the material of an architect so it's
not he's not the only
one alone at the table creating but
we have to be used to work together with
scientists
with botanists with with sociologists
with economic involved people so it's a
it's a big bunch
of people and as an architect i'm a
practicing architect i'm on my way
learning to be engaged in all these
questions
and having all these people in a team
and we showed it within our future
cities lab team
together with with thomas and the whole
team that we were
all interdisciplinary and we had to
learn
like stephen said our different
languages
english was our let's say common ground
but it's not english alone there are
different
english and different languages
so we had really to understand each
other respect
each other and these are maybe some new
topics to be
achieved in the future when you work as
an architect when you work as an urban
planner
thank you sasha so talking about
different disciplines we have a
landscape architect industry so sri as a
landscape architect can you share with
us what is the value of integrated open
space
thank you geraldine and good evening
everybody
yeah i do bring one of the dimensions
which sasha mentioned
and i think integrated green open spaces
are actually
extremely um critical in
when we talk about livability when we
talk about
sustainability in density and high
density environments
so the open spaces of course they give
you
all the values which thomas has already
shared which is
environmental ecological social
um the health and well-being benefits
and of course the economic benefits but
i think there are a few more dimensions
which it adds
one is which i think is very very
significant
is the idea of accessibility and
connectivity
i think once you integrate buildings not
just at the ground level but at multiple
levels as we are
moving vertical it kind of brings those
spaces
right to your doorsteps and i think in
today's uh
today's living having the access
nature at your doorstep is a luxury and
what we have seen
is um that is where there is the
difference of
a high density city becoming livable
uh versus becoming um you know a
concrete jungle
so um that's a very very significant
value which
integrated open spaces at and of course
the aesthetics
and the branding and the image of
more integrated green spaces is also
something which is
extremely valuable towards
having a city perceived as livable yeah
thank you stream
so today we have in our title is dance
and green city so there are two
components the dance part and the green
part
right so um for stephen in your work
you've explored different kinds of
settlements and different kind of
densities
is there such thing as a good density or
bad density can
good density be designed the simple
answer is yes
um there must be a good and there must
be a bad density otherwise they wouldn't
need designers
to manage it um but of course the really
interesting
thing and that is the devil is in the
detail um
you know as mark has already alluded
density is
is really significant issue again uh for
a long time everybody basically felt
that
a good city was a dense city um
of course there was always los angeles
and there was always you know sprawl
sprawl conditions but generally people
thought that high-density cities
were with the right way to make cities
and you can think about threat from the
singaporean agencies like the ura the
statutory planning authority
uh the housing authority you could go to
the world bank
the u.n the ipcc even this is the agency
looking at planetary climate change
still regards the city as a dense city
as a good city
now of course that's all um up for
debate again
and i think there's the data is is just
not available to us we simply don't know
the effects of density and and the
pandemic
um but it's very useful to rethink about
rethink density again
um density is a really beautiful
uh term of course it doesn't mean we're
talking obviously inside a disciplinary
framework
we're not talking about the density of
stone or wood we're talking about
population density so how populations
are gathered together
as thomas already alluded to this is not
only the population of people there's
population of
animals perhaps and bugs and i noticed a
couple of people asking about mosquitoes
so there's an ecological density that
goes with it we've got to think a little
bit about that and i think thomas's
uh book has already sketched that stuff
out so
density is very important to understand
we talk about population density
um it's also related to a number of
other words
it's related to other words like
intensity and compactness
tightness uh crowdedness
in fact it's quite different from
crowdedness so the benefits of density
lie
in intensity density it can also flip
to becoming a very very dangerous
condition
which is why density is very important
in an urban design in the sense it's
very important to distinguish from
crowdedness
so you can have very high quality
density
which is managed by the reason in the
way that this three was talking about
how you access it how do you access the
outdoors how do you how do you get
public transport how close are jobs
can you access uh simple things like
electricity
the wi-fi the internet if all of these
things are not available
then that density very quickly turns
into a kind of crowded condition which
is a very
dangerous and and as we started to see
probably quite a threatening
a threatening situation so density is
very tricky term it's right
back in the uh in the in the darker
public opinion i think it's a very
very important very timely study that
we're starting to think about that
question
as always it's in a city which is one of
as we all know is one of the most
complex human artifacts
ever made it's never one thing it's
never just density
you can have very high quality density
and as we've seen in singapore you get
high quality densities and you also get
low quality densities
as we saw through the the dorms
so at the moment singapore is going
through a really interesting discussion
about how to handle
these diverse kinds of density and
become again this really important kind
of model for a certain
kind of high density and very
responsible
responsible urbanism thank you stephen
so i will summarize that density is a
complex issue
so then the next question goes to the
complexity scientist
to roland so roland as a complexity
scientist can you provide some insights
on human movement in a dense environment
and how human movement may make some
places more or less vulnerable
thank you very much geraldine and indeed
it's a fantastic transition uh you know
from from stephen to to myself
uh because over the last year or so my
research team and i we have been working
on a particular question of
human movement in the third dimension a
lot of work has been done on you know
how people move in just you know two
dimensions but
uh third i mentioned the vertical
dimension is extremely important
indeed density in cities often rhymes
with verticality
and very little is known about you know
how we move up and down
in those vertical cities so our results
uh showing that some very unique
patterns of human vertical movement are
taking place
so with thomas uh right now we have uh
we're working on a very exciting project
aim at uh essentially quantifying the
influence of green spaces
uh especially when they are vertically
distributed in buildings
uh and how they affect human movement so
this uh clearly will ease the congestion
that you have on the ground floor
uh and also on the ground as well and
also providing a positive human building
interaction
now of course with kovid 19 density goes
against the new rules of
social distancing so there comes a
question of how do we deal with
high density places and obviously
density has a very clear definition from
the scientific perspective
but density varies widely in the city
and one you know
we you know we might think that uh there
are only places with high density that
would be vulnerable to disease
transmission like
the central business district but it
turns out that the reality is actually
more complex than that
um what really matters uh are actually
the patterns of human co-presence when
we get into contact
whether at work or it could be in public
spaces including
public transports and and stephen
mentioned uh what happens in the dorms
and foreign workers and these are
essentially this is a separate
population so they have a lot of cases
uh but it's confined to the dorms uh
because they actually do not interact
much with the rest of the population in
singapore
but what will happen if you have a
bridge between those dorms
and the community so the really the
patterns of human co-presence are truly
essential now
how can we make uh some of these places
less vulnerable that's
that's a tricky question if you use
large-scale network-based models of
human compressors for instance
uh along with big data that can help us
chart how people
within a particular location connect and
interact
the idea of doing you know population
contact tracing is
i think almost impossible in practice to
do
uh but if you have this kind of of
simple models of co presents you know
coupled with
specific epidemiological models then you
have the potential to
identify uh what we can call super
spreader locations
places uh where there is a high risk of
transmission and this will also help the
governments in terms of having targeted
measures
right now what we have around the world
at least in singapore is a blanket ban
you know lockdowns for everyone but
obviously not all places are created
equal and not all places deserve to be
under lockdown
so those models could actually help in
two ways
uh first to avoid you know what some
people call the
virus fatigue which is going to wear out
communities and cause people to lower
the guard against the disease
but also i help the government optimize
in terms of deploying resources to the
places that really
need to be that i consider deliverable
and dangerous
yeah thank you roland this pretty much
goes out to
thomas in summary of two questions by
rajiv as well as max kohler
the question goes does the maintenance
of green buildings use much resources
and generate more waste
with technologies such as ai driven ai
driven systems mitigate this
it's actually a great question uh for
the research that we do
and it's it's particularly if i can you
know
uh bring the question to shri because
she's the landscape architect
uh on the on the team she has also
worked with us
on particularly those questions uh
construction and maintenance costs uh
that are
affiliated with uh dance and green
building typologies
so shree if you don't mind would you
like to say something about this
the first the first question i think the
second one we can we can take both
the perception that maintenance of all
these uh
dense and green buildings is very
expensive um
it can be dealt with at a very initial
stages of design
um if they were very expensive you won't
see so many
of them being built you know so
what we saw was that the projects which
addressed the concerns of long-term
maintenance access
safety requirements if all these have
been addressed up front in the design
using very simple um inclusions like you
know having
access to the planting areas and making
sure that you don't
expect them to hang from gondolas to
maintain them
uh the general cost for maintenance has
been uh
quite reasonable because uh eventually
the costs go high
when you need um high skilled workers to
maintain
so if the maintenance regimen is similar
to what you would do on the ground
the costs are not very high so i think
at the end of the day it also depends on
how you
detail and how you design these uh
multi-level
uh green systems yeah
so i've i can i can take the second part
of the
the question which was on the use of
technology right and
ai uh we found in our research that
often and architects have experimented
with all sorts of ways for irrigation
for example in in the dense and green
buildings that we studied
over the years and what we found is that
it's often
the the very simple details that do not
require a lot of mechanical you know
maintenance or any kind of technological
uh component that worked the best
so if you if you take for example o asia
hotel downtown that we looked at a
couple of times
today the detail is really very simple
you have a screen that is
filled with creepers that grow through
the screen and along the screen
and there is on every level or every
other level there's a planter box
and anyone can go there and just water
the plants right so it's that simple
uh complicated technological systems
they tend to
fail that has to do with
simply the scale of buildings and the
fact that they're exposed to the
elements
i wouldn't exclude the possibility that
they are very very smart systems that
can help us i mean particularly in the
realm of ai that we're only starting to
explore what the possibilities are
but the experience with these buildings
over the last couple of years has
actually shown that
the simpler the detail the better it
seems to work
would you agree shree yeah i have to
agree on that that it's it's actually
about the detail
if we can um put a little bit more time
and effort in detailing these
in the long run they are not as
expensive or as difficult
yeah i just like to add that very
important is the
balance between the inputs
and the outputs what i want to say is
that
you get benefits with the greenery so
you do a
let's say a primary investment but
let's say on the on the energetic
performance of a building
if you keep it technically
on a on a very basic as thomas said on a
basic level
you can get a lot of energetic positive
performance this is just what i want to
say so you do
you you give a monetary input at the
beginning
but you get a payback
at the end and this is always you have
to balance
this when you when you start your
planning
and keep the details as easy as possible
like thomas said
so it's basically some kind of a
cost-benefit analysis right from the
beginning that's right
yeah okay um for the next question
is to do with food so this question by
jayden
the question goes addressing food
security is one of the key national
agendas at the moment
can we integrate community scale food
production seamlessly into green
building design
i'm going to give this a step i'll
probably need a little bit of help from
the rest
especially on the technical parts but uh
um
i think definitely regards to sort of uh
increasing
um more domestic production of food in
vertical cities in densities will be
needed for
any city and of course in particular
cities like singapore
where we depend a lot on sort of uh
diverse
uh channels for food supply um
i think that's something singapore has
um
planned i think there's a the goal is
about to hit 30
uh domestic production in the next
couple of years but also i
find help but see that
home that ambition being able to
co-mingle with this
easily in a dense green city
right because if you are have the
ability to plan for vertical
environments integrating greenery
i think hence there might be a ability
a natural ability to be able to then
think about how can that greenery
potentially be used for food um so i
think that's
going to be a very natural reality for
all of us
i feel that those things will become
more common especially in situations
increasingly
and i'm in eventually it will become
just part and parcel of
how you live right just being able to
step out of your high rise
to a green patch and as well as to farm
some
some food yeah thank you mark
um i know that stephen is very
passionate about growing your own food
as well stephen you have something to
say about this
yeah thanks for spotting my itchy finger
there
i like really uh i love growing
vegetables um
but that's not what my point i would
just want to add to what mark was saying
i think this is an immensely interesting
area um singapore is really working hard
on this
and it has this very memorable policy
goal of 30
of domestic food production by 2030. so
30 by 30. keep that in mind
most people say it's incredibly
difficult and very challenging to do
that
um and but what i find very interesting
about it is it it's clearly what you can
grow outside your window or even on more
complex uh you know exoskeleton type
structures you can kind of imagine
coming out of
the work that thomas and sasha have
already sketched you can already see
emerging models
especially in some of the more
speculative things that ohio is doing in
the studio
it's clear that this is not going to
deliver you the efficiencies of
industrialized food production
so you're still going to have to be
importing um you know from the giant
rice farms all around asia
the wheat from the u.s or australia and
so on you simply can't compete
at a local kind of fragmented sort of
cottage industry level
but at the higher end of the market the
boutique and the very high value crops
particularly if you have a very very
short
you know farm to farm to table
sensitivity once logistics comes into
you can get incredibly high value and i
think economically very very relevant
models
for um for producing food much closer to
the city itself
and again one of the things that's
that's emerged in the in the current
pandemic
um is precisely the like the length of
the supply chains to cities all around
the world but especially singapore
where the city boundary is also a
national boundary so there's a huge
amount of work being going on with the
singapore food
a agency modelling these kinds of supply
chains
and i would just underline despite all
of this singapore still ranks number one
in the world for food security quite
amazing
it's being it's being eroded rapidly by
the covert situation
so it's dropping down very quickly but
nonetheless it's still number one in the
world so it's quite an amazing
situation i think this direction is very
very very exciting
so thanks for asking me to tune in on
that topic you're welcome
geraldine can i say something to this uh
i think when when singapore is referring
to 30 by 30
of course you cannot achieve this with
the kind of community
uh urban farming that we saw in the case
of kutek quad hospital
right i mean that just adds to food
coming from from somewhere else but
i think a goal like this can only be
achieved through
very interesting use of of technology
right often these farms are entirely
inside of buildings they're artificially
led
so that is actually an area where a lot
of technology
advancements take place so there are all
sorts of interesting things that are
explored right now
and it is it is quite different from
you know the greenery that we have
referred to in uh
in the presentation even though there is
as i said and we see this with the
student projects in the university when
uh
students get to own uh to choose their
own topic for let's say a thesis project
there's a tremendous interest
in the younger generation in exploring
uh you know food production urban
farming
as a topic in architecture and landscape
architecture thank you very much
thomas the next question i believe goes
out to roland
this is about movement of people so what
else should we consider when designing
cities for walkability
in terms of land use how should city
planners in order to make a city more
livable be able to encourage better
interface
between different projects not only
horizontally but also vertically
a great great question so i i i'm afraid
all of us are going to
sound like we're promoting singapore and
doing publicity for what the the
government is doing but it's true that
there are many
uh this is already something going on in
singapore trying to improve
walkability uh and the distribution of
parks
and how you move as i said how we move
in in three dimensions
so let me just touch on this particular
question because i think
you know singapore is doing something
different and it's easy to understand so
if you go to another big asian city
let's say you go to
shenzhen or some other place
in hong kong for instance typically
moving up and down means that you are
taking an elevator
right between the top of a skyscraper to
the the ground floor
and uh simple as that so your vertical
movement is
limited and often just based on an
elevator ride but in singapore
you have a different use of the vertical
dimension
thomas shown the um the component mirror
t building
where you can gradually go from one
floor to another
by you know being outdoor walking
outdoor
so that reduces the use of air
conditioning for instance at the same
time you are enjoying greenery
so this is this is something that we
could promote
on the larger scale at the city level
where different buildings like that will
be integrated
there are some some examples uh in place
in singapore where you have
a multi stations connected to shopping
centers that are connected to
hospitals for instance i think about
jurong east
uh and where the government is trying to
also
have you know the pedestrians have
access without the cars being around and
all the traffic being
uh being separated the car traffic being
separated so your experience would be
better because
you enjoy walking more if you are not
you know surrounded by cars if you don't
have the exhaust from the cars
on the top of that it improves the
connectivity between buildings so there
is indeed a lot of work that can be done
but this has to be done as i said not
just at the building level
it has to be integrated at the district
level
um across um uh different plots
and this is where you know the
government
governments have to be involved because
only they can essentially help
facilitate that take place between
different different plots when they do
a new district development for instance
so there is a real
uh possibility to bring down the density
by having people working at different
levels
accessibility is the big big trigger so
if we if we can engage planners
if you can engage also the authorities
and even even the the
the investors in this sense then we need
really to talk about accessibility
of a building because usually buildings
are privatized and
it's is it the common space the green
space is it
is it a public space which makes it a
lot more difficult
and i think here's a kind of a trigger
here we have to
to debate it and we have to be
open-minded because here
new models come up of accessibilities of
buildings
in the in the future if
in singapore you have a lot of very good
examples
about about this let's say open space
and open accessible buildings but not
all of them not all of them
are and this i think is is a challenge
is a challenge for the future we have to
think about that
thank you sasha okay i think we have a
final question how do we design for
safety
i think especially in the time of
pandemic which we're all experiencing
now
our lives have changed drastically in
the past few months
how can we design for safety and for
resilience yeah
just to riff a little bit on the last uh
thread
um i think safety ends it ends up in a
slightly
narrow area you know of health and
safety but i think resilience is a very
interesting
uh topic and i was just thinking a
little bit about what roland was saying
um you know we end up we do end up
reflect
reflecting a lot in these kinds of
environments about the the amazing
things that have been done in singapore
but when you come to nature it is quite
interesting to see where the limits are
because singapore
as a city-state um increasingly has to
start to think
in a way about asean as a larger
ecosystem
so i think many i was reading some of
the the threads in
in the book so if you look at bird
migration species for example
they're not living within the bounds of
the nation state of singapore of course
these are these are
long-distance travelers sometimes um so
in a way singapore
uh is starting then in that respect
thinking about this broader question of
nature and
resilience it started to become a part
considering itself much more within a
kind of regional ecology
and i think that's typical for an
outlook of a nation state that has a lot
of
land um like the united states or europe
for example
or australia but singapore has to think
itself
much more as a kind of um as a kind of
archipelago
in this larger kind of framework of
nature and i think that's also starting
to emerge
in the way singapore is is often taking
a very
progressive role in asean so
transnational
associations and of course this has a
this has an ecological dimension
for those of you who live in singapore
we know that we suffer
this very complicated you know process
of the haze
which is a trans-border ecological
disaster
and i think if you scale it up to kind
of the level of coded
we have to be thinking across
trans-border logics and i think they're
paying attention to nature um slightly
beyond the scale of the building and the
urban plot
starts to become very very interesting
and i think very important to the bigger
question of relevance of resilience
thank you um i noticed that three has a
response as well
and on top of what you're going to
respond i'm going to piggyback one last
question which i think is probably
meant for you how do you think other
parts of the world can follow
singapore's examples
do you believe that legislations should
change and consider integration of green
space in new buildings first is the
first response in terms of the safety
it's quite an interesting component like
you know how your view safety kind of
changes
depending on what becomes a factor
to be safe from right i know when we
were designing these buildings for a
long time the safety was more about
how to make sure that people are safe
when they maintain these buildings or
how do you make sure that construction
time the safety is
managed and now the safety aspect has
moved to health
hygiene interaction um
you know even um co-location whether
it's safe
so um i think for us it needs to be more
adaptable be able to change be able to
respond i think that is where uh
safety aspect comes in for singapore
because it's not as straightforward as a
blanket
way of dealing with safety and in terms
of
singapore example of green yes
of course there needs to be legislation
changes and
the reason why we see these kind of
dense and green integrated buildings in
singapore i have to say
uh was triggered by the change in
policies
like lush like skyrise greenery like
you know the green mark the leaf area
index the need for
green plot ratios so there needs to be
a change in legislation and policies to
make sure that
it kind of uh in a way forces people to
think about new way of designing these
buildings and integrating green space
um and over the span of time when people
start looking at
um the value it adds i think it becomes
a practice you don't need legislation
after that you would do it because
it gives you the benefits um so yes if
you have to change
i think the first step is to make sure
that there is a policy change there is a
legislation change
to how you design buildings in the first
place
thank you i think with that
we will wrap up the q a and i would like
to invite
each panelist to give a closing
statement
one liner about what's the key takeaway
from the discussion and the
presentations uh
this evening so maybe um can i start
with thomas
okay thank you geraldine uh in my case
it's not a one-liner it's a
multi-multi-liner
i think developing compact cities with
extensive greenery and highly
livable environments is really a very
important strategy in addressing rapid
urbanization
i think innovative dense and green
design
in my opinion can contribute
significantly
to the creation of attractive and
ecologically balanced urban environments
by offering a wide range
of urban architectural environmental
social
and economic benefits and i think the
benefits also include
a higher level of resilience in a
situation like the one we're in right
now
it might not help directly with the
virus when you're infected but certainly
to survive the situation you know not to
die from cabin fever it is really
important to be in an environment that
is
dense as singapore but at the same time
allows us to go out and reach a green
space
very very quickly i think that makes a
huge uh
difference in terms of resilience of the
city
thank you thomas may i next invite mark
to give a closing statement
since thomas did it i'll give a few
lines
and not just one line um
i think one thing is people actually
still i would have taken away from this
whole thing
is people will still want to interact
and enjoy the city
but they also now want to feel safe so
the challenge actually now is actually
how do you create those same dynamic
desired experiences while also upholding
all these new guidelines
that we'll see formed in the year in the
months to come
on the years to come but generally
people may not visit spaces if their
experiences promises to be stressful
but i also believe that as more people
still want to move to cities for
opportunities
then people also work more from home
and hence like now after sitting at your
desk
for the entire day looking at your
screen on your breaks or at the end of
the day we actually need green spaces to
easily get too quickly
beyond the planned trip to the nature
reserve the 10 to 15 minute walk
in and out of the city so i believe that
there'll be a need
actually in my view there's a need for a
wider range of
nature spaces made accessible to people
in terms of size
perhaps character and of course
programming
and these could be places for 1 2 5
10 or 100 people to escape to to enjoy
the outdoors because more people will
want to go to the outdoors now uh to be
enjoyed quickly
or longer but most importantly this new
thing about safely
yeah thank you mark um i think we should
then move on to the landscape architects
three
what's your response i have to agree to
the points which thomas
and mark have already said but for me
the the key aspect is that the value of
having
uh green open spaces a close proximity
where you can just step down and be able
to reach
um is something um which has been more
pronounced
in the current situation than before and
we
tend to start valuing every bit of green
space which we
have around us um so while we
um are addressing all these challenges
of the pandemic
i also see on a positive note that there
are
quite interesting uh positives to take
from uh like there is community
resilience which we have seen
we've seen spatial adaptability we've
seen improved environmental quality
we've seen vibrant biodiversity um there
is an increased awareness of health and
hygiene and also there is a fostering
of a sustainable lifestyle so um
all these are forced temporary
transformations but
it might just encourage equitable and
sustainable urban future
actually um and in a way accelerate the
global response to larger issues of uh
climate change and global warming thank
you sri
um zooming out as you mentioned global
issues um perhaps we can have roland
give the next statement thank you all
right so uh i'll be very short just two
words
uh interdisciplinary design okay
let me elaborate a bit i think the
solution to all these problems is to
bring
you know architects uh designers
scientists complexity scientists
you know uh uh ecological scientists you
bring them together
right to design a better city you you
read in a newspaper now that you know
because of kovid right people are
essentially fleeing cities and
considering their new life
in going out of city i just don't
believe in that i
i don't buy it i think you know for sure
you know some cities
are fully designed and they don't have a
high quality of living
but a well-designed cities with you know
greenery
where you can meet your friends and it's
a fantastic city
so but that's that requires uh good
design
uh interdisciplinary design so i'll
close with this thank you very much
and i think the next natural person to
respond to interdisciplinary design
would be steven
yes um well it's it's been a super
interesting
um evening you can see dusk going down
outside my window
for me the the really exciting aspects
are
in a way this kind of format this is a
kind of meeting that we could not
possibly have had
if we'd all flown taken flights although
we'd love to host you all in singapore
and we could have shown you a really
great time
there's fantastic food fantastic public
spaces
but in a way we all know carbon
footprint all kinds of other financial
issues simply don't make that possible
so i think there's a kind of emerging
kind of spider density
which becomes super interesting and we
all have had those headaches right where
you get this
very very sort of intense zoom
experience i think it's the beginning of
another kind of urban experience
it doesn't deny the other one but the
two are kind of inter
interlinked and the fact that we can
talk to people
you know like sasha in switzerland and
here and everybody else
online i think is starting to point the
way
to another kind of density and i think
mark alluded to it as well
that density has to be embedded in the
physical density of the house
and if you don't happen to have a very
nice house
if it's just one room and you happen to
have young children there and you happen
to be the woman
who typically looks after the household
then this is a very very
stressful environment so the cyber
physical future world
is not so it's not so so much fun so i
think we have to think about the
domestic very very ordinary density
plus the new possibilities of this kind
of density
i'm an architect so i'm always a little
bit upbeat about this so um i'm looking
forward to the next discussion thanks
again
thank you stephen for your upbeat final
closing statement
and sasha your closing statement please
yes thank you
to all of you with your final statements
which i
absolutely absolutely agree and i wanted
to
point more on on the rollouts on honor's
final statements
and of course you did it and i don't
have to repeat it and i'm happy hold on
that we will be
working together in the future but what
i want to say is that since 1950 and
nowadays in the last 70 years in europe
especially in switzerland
housing space private space has
increased
about 30 percent so houses get bigger
and in the last 10 years i experienced
that housing space decreases because of
price
the price of the of the land and
i think we're going to do a big mistake
making our houses smaller
i think exactly now we experience
what it is steven in his house is a
happy man
me and my apartment which has different
spaces
to to go to is is fantastic so
the question of the experience
expand to expand green space
into the vertical in especially in asia
in europe a little bit less
but this is a is a dramatic important
there's a dramatic important question
and we have really to rethink
our real estate ideas i'm talking to the
developers
and i'm talking also to the people
in in governments releasing the rules
how we have to build in the future
so this this for my opinion will be one
of the
real big challenges and the other one is
if we introduce the greenery
into our houses into the vertical we
have even to rethink our relation
to nature it's a different nature we
have
as it is outside of our buildings
goodbye from switzerland thank you very
much
thank you for having me in this
discussion
thank you thank you very much to all the
panelists
um the truth is today's topics have been
extremely diverse and we still have many
questions that we cannot answer in this
two-hour
webinar so firstly we would like to
apologize we are deeply sorry that they
are still open questions
but what we are extremely happy about is
that this session has provoked questions
to question the status quo and to
challenge your imagination
so we would like to thank all of you for
joining us this evening or this morning
wherever you are from
and hope that you have gained some
interesting insights almost finally
as much as we cannot see every one of
you in this virtual environment
the sharing the lively discussion and
the energy is real so thank you very
much for sharing this evening or your
morning with us
um i would like to thank especially our
superheroes behind the scene
so if everything has been running pretty
smoothly they are because it's just
because they're superheroes behind
doing all this work um working
tirelessly to make this event happen
so special thanks goes out to daniel
wong from sutd
and janine liu from design singapore
council and also to the rest of the
design singapore team
a very very big thank you to you this is
um i've said all my thanks i wish you a
very very pleasant evening ahead
keep well good night and hope to see you
again soon
thank you thank you thank you
you